hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to slime rancher now
this is the full release of the game
this isn't in the early access anymore
this isn't in beta this isn't the demo
and that avatar is actually really cute
oh look at the style about so slime
rancher is fully released but I don't
intend to do a full series of this but I
do want to play a few episodes at this
because I really did enjoy the game it
just didn't seem like there was a lot of
content there so going back into it I'm
ready to see what they have from the
very start this is game marki new save
icon is markiplier over there okay
adventure lived the life of a slime
rancher and explore the far wonders of
the far far range at your own pace a mad
sprint for the most new bucks you can
earn in five days bragging is encouraged
I'm down for that but I kind of want to
explore my own pace here I really do
explore my own pace one in 24 characters
all right how about marquee move Rancho
real good how about marquee moon Rancho
real good how about marquee Moran how
about what roll good there we go that's
the winner there all right what did what
slang is that the thousand light-years
away from Earth oh my god plot on a
planet known as the far far range be a
tricks in the bub begins her first day
as a slime rancher am i Beatrix am i
miss Luba my lip line so this all looks
relatively the same oh you're gonna get
shocked sorry
just a nice [ __ ] ah Destin good [ __ ] get
me oh that's nice how to vac like a
rancher your vac pack can fact things up
and store them in the fact tank hold
right mouse button to FAC oh I think I
know how to vac I know all about this
sucking the blow of slime rancher
all right you bastards let's see all
right where are you gonna do can you
take Krupa Dube all right I remember eat
this and draw big and give me your money
give me your poop
sweet slime poop that's everything I've
ever wanted
you've act a slime I got Munns well I've
already done this someone do it again
just to the tutorial to be happy about
its life
hey you slime boy get over ere I need to
get more rare slimes later but for now
you're gonna do alright you don't escape
now Oh what are you doing over there you
gonna get in your VAT boink
oh you hesitating cuz you bashed your
brain up against the silo No
ain't gonna do that alright I gotta go
get slimes or I gotta go get vegetables
for you to eat you little ungrateful
bastards I probably should have I
probably should have yeah I probably
should have planted those crops oh look
more crops scoodle II doodly-doo thank
you it's good to leave me you how are
you come here I got a VAT that you guys
want to get it you guys want to get
sucked into my backpack no no sorry your
whole family's in my backpack you can't
escape from that you know how to run
away from your destiny do you my house I
don't think I put that there
or whatever do you do good okay can't
have too many of you here eat one to two
carrots and I'm gonna Plourd it up over
your point point point point point point
yeah yeah alright I can plant me some
carrots no that is not how that works I
forget how that works why am I talking
in southern accent I don't even remember
orgeous yay point point point point
oh okay nevermind then that I only
needed one it but I needed more than one
but apparently it's need one so while
that's growing I'm gonna go out and get
more booby dues hello hello Beatrix the
names Hobson twill gas Rancho Explorer
and the former owner of this here ranch
you call your own
pleased to make your acquaintance I was
a rancher for more years than I can
remember
and felt there was one last adventure
left in me so I set off to find just
that but before I go I'm taking one last
tour around the earth this here land I
love to keep your peepers peeled for
notes like these if you want to hear
what it has to say I got star mail I'll
get that later oh hello well then I uh
exactly ready to have you on board just
yet oh they gave me an achievement oh
that's so sweet of them I don't know
what it means but I got one oh is that a
chickadee oh well no can't do that just
yet I'll get a chicken farm later but I
got to get I got to start from like
meager beginnings at first and then grow
later into my girthy more robust farm
you acquired a slime floor I know what a
slime floor do buddy I've handled more
poop than you could put your eyes on so
don't even think that you can tell me
how to put all about the poop market
these days okay oh no you can't get out
yeah that's right cuz that's how that's
supposed to be just eaten shut up eat
your goddamn pooping food and shut up
all right yep I know I know floored it
up gimme gimme gimme gimme all your
floors okay you did good you did good
could use some more poop next time but
hey beggars can't be choosers so just
get in there and stop being stupid man I
sure AM insulting hey you're all
adorable and I love you you're doing
great at whatever it is you do every day
which is just smile eating poop which
frankly you know hey I wish I could live
like that let me see how I can build
another
in here and then I can build it build a
Pogo fruit Boober
maybe this tip will be happy about that
yeah I don't like the way that bulbous
eats I don't like that at all that felt
weird so I don't have enough I'm gonna
put you all in here I know you guys are
gonna get be [ __ ] about it must be a
bunch of douches you just take that food
you eat up I'll be back all right don't
go nowhere I know I know I curse the
basics I get it I'm smart I'm a smart I
got smart brains in my smart face I got
a big ol head in my side mama in my bad
brain
chickadee do oh it's not a chicken dance
that you can do oh look at the kitty
cats well I got chickadees now so I
guess I'm gonna be going for the tabby
it's a hybrid what do we do I can't suck
you you Largo bastard valuable port a
rock Wow my analyst all right well
anyway I've got a rock Plourd that's
worth of one show this one but let me
see what this guy talking this entire
cave system was sealed off from a
cave-in when I first discovered it maybe
that's why the fellers up ahead or so
grumpy haven't had a bite in a long time
in any case don't let that long-awaited
bite come from your own rump bring some
food to calm them down bring some food
to come home down ooh what kind of ploy
to be talking about over wool they're
angry oh hi hey I know okay all right I
am NOT okay with that I will be back in
just a jiffy sir oh that's awesome oh
that's so cool I got the whole map now
oh look at me how many secrets are there
oh it's huge
oh it's whoo gay oh it's so much bigger
man I guess it has been a while since I
last played this music come on you
tabbies Maya I said get in mate
and I'm just gonna fill up on tap oh hey
buddies I'm gonna fill up on tabbies cuz
I want a full full assortment at taboos
whoa that was a that was a male
chickadee I need you I need you more
than I need a hen hen ah stony chick
wait no what a stony chick oh that's
weird
oh hello alright it's almost night time
which means that the demons are almost
here all right I'm fall on floor it's
there I had a great big tree like this
here long edge of my property back on
earth has been there before anybody
could remember it survived all kinds of
change around it and then one day I
began noticing it was dying wasn't
anything unnatural just said it's time I
suppose and then I realized that if I
didn't do something I'd end up like that
tree I spent my whole life in the same
place I'm going to let that happen so I
bought a ticket to the Far Far range the
very next day oh that's so lovely I I
marginally care I think but I've got to
get back before the nightmares come and
kill me need all the other slimes I mean
what a life just happy smiling during
the day and then nighttime everyone gets
eaten and killed and waited doodlee
doodlee me get out of my way before I
kill you
oh did need to I'm gonna feed that guy
very soon the big old lord over there oh
man I miss having all my upgrades
especially my jet pack and whatnot but
I'm gonna get there oh I got a chickadee
over here oh that's awfully nice of you
thanks for actually being there oh
that's so sweet dish dish dish [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] good touch those guys got gush so
I need to build two more I'll take I
need to build a chicken head and more
than anything cube okay
poink oh don't you think you can run for
me hello why didn't know it chickens ear
alright you grow up big and strong hope
this doesn't hurt you anyway alright and
then I'm gonna need to tap you later but
I don't want to get these eyes guys
intermingled
give me your lords give me your Lords
dude a get back in there you big [ __ ]
eat there right in his mouth did I get
an achievement for that to sailing right
into the mouth of a one okay there's
that we've got 270 which is enough for
another pen where I can put the tabbies
in should be anyway boink all right get
in there you tabby bastards I'll have
chickens for you when they're all grown
up sorry mother hens your adoptive
children are gonna be fed to the cats I
have no sympathy oh whoa what are you oh
look at you catch you want to care it
do you eat carrot oh you eat fruit no I
don't have any fruit on me right now
I'll say wood fruit you guys up maybe I
could go get something to be worth it to
go get some fruit I don't know why the
demons aren't attacking maybe they
changed that in the story where they
don't attack initially anyway
oh hey you flying guys you want some
fruit hey num poop-poop for me thank you
that's a nice poop that's a quality poop
right there hey oh you ate it over there
well you greedy piece of [ __ ] give me my
fruit back you get out of here you want
some point point
don't give it to those goddamn pink
slimes not who deserves it I don't have
the money to build a pen for them or
else I would get him up but just don't
need them right now oh yeah
why'd you blam blam on me oh that sounds
bad that sounds like the bad music
are we bad why are we bad why we bad
ladies and gentlemen why are we bad [ __ ]
o'clock o'clock whoa no no no no give oh
no no no give me give me give me yes
rooster oh hey you're gonna make lots of
food you're gonna make lots of babies
Moo stro let's go a little farther into
the expo hi kitty cat
oh it's kitty cat oh I'll get you later
I need to get the big the other grab Oh
first I think I need to get back I got
rooster oh I got some good of these uh
these phosphor plots and sweet glowing
poops which are worth way more than the
pink ones I believe Hey oh you word yo
the tar oh okay oh there's the tar I was
waiting for that to come around
God the opposite of the slime I suppose
but still I don't know why they exist
I let me go ahead and dump all the rest
of my fruit that I got one on this guy
hey catch catch yeah you don't even eat
it anymore you just absorb it India
that's somehow even more disturbing all
right well whatever
rooster oh this rooster don't even think
about it buddy and I'm such a dedicated
farmer no sleep for me just constant
work no matter what no matter what gets
in my way
hey you wanna I don't have any more all
right never mind man forget I said
anything in fact go [ __ ] yourself
because I don't I don't even want to
talk to you anymore
I don't even want you near my farm you
don't deserve to be here all right
Irie stro no this is pretty where you
die let me put you in here hey procreate
your roost oh guy oh that means I can
sacrifice one of you all righty then
tabby well they are liking those move
they're liking those over there all
right anyway I'll get you all right
whatever that that King Han is gonna
have his Philbin not from these and
hence sadly this is the way nature works
for all right not bad not bad not bad
okay I think it's time to turn it in for
the night that was a good day oh look
how cute I am
star mail rise and shine what's it like
to sleep for a year I think I got I got
um I got these before so I think I'm
fine sleep till morning
yeah those anyway so this is slime
rancher I want to play a few more videos
of this I want to make I want to play a
few more I want to make a few more
videos whoo this just because like it's
really cool and I want to see like the
depths that it has now just because
slime rancher is such a weirdly like
pleasant game it has like I love farming
games like I love stardew valley when it
came out and I like these these relaxing
farming games but this one also has just
an element of weird mystery to it how
are you guys new new cats in the area
you sure are bouncy bastards so anyway
so that is slime answer for now I do
want to make a few more videos of this
and if you guys have seen more hey don't
escape if you guys have seen more stuff
to do in slime rancher let me know down
in the comments below thanks again
everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]